homenaje en la ciudad de niza a las 3
personas que perdieron la vida en el
ataque terrorista el ministro del
interior francés estuvo de visita en
túnez país de donde provenía el atacante
con el fin de extraditar a un grupo de
ciudadanos tunecinos en situación
irregular en francia
consideramos que esta ideología no tiene
nada que ver con las religiones como
bien lo dijo usted pero esta ideología
hay que combatirla le agradezco señor
ministro después del largo intercambio
que tuvimos para poder seguir haciendo
este trabajo para intercambiar nuestra
información
y luchar contra aquellos que quieren
destruir nuestra amistad y la relación
fraterna entre nuestros pueblos y la
hora son extranjeros plantar el primer
ministro jan que ustedes preside el
homenaje también estará presente el ex
presidente nicolas sarkozy si francia es
el país con la población musulmana más
numerosa de europa austria tienen su
suelo una de las mayores concentraciones
musulmanas del continente en proporción
a su población de 89 millones de
habitantes el gobierno ordenó el cierre
de mezquitas radicales tras el atentado
en viena perpetrado por un islamista
radical que asesinó a cuatro personas
es canonizado en escalones fast bandas
no puede ser verdad que los jóvenes de
hoy piensen que van al cielo si matan a
alguien el imán dijo que es culpa de los
padres creo que los padres son en parte
culpables tienen que hacer seguimiento
de la educación de sus hijos miembros de
la comunidad musulmana judía y cristiana
en berlín se reunieron frente a la
embajada de austria en homenaje a las
víctimas las autoridades germanas buscan
actualmente a cuatro personas que se
cree tenían vínculos con el atacante de
viena